nos preguntan cuáles de las siguientes
rectas son perpendiculares y aquí
tenemos tres rectas de las cuales dos de
estas tres rectas deben de ser
perpendiculares entre sí pues no se
puede ser perpendicular a sí misma y
bueno si hablamos de rectas
perpendiculares y para que visualicen
mejor cómo se vean rectas
perpendiculares dos rectas son
perpendiculares si se intersectan en
ángulos rectos si está que trazo aquí es
una de las rectas entonces una recta
perpendicular se va a ver así esta va a
ser una recta perpendicular porque va a
interceptar a la otra pero no en
cualquier intersección va a interceptar
la otra en ángulos rectos en una
intersección muy especial ahora sí dos
rectas son perpendiculares y voy a decir
que la pendiente de esta recta rojiza es
m con esto vamos a decir que su ecuación
es james igual a mx más y vamos a decir
un talde uno una intersección con el eje
del ay es entonces la ecuación que está
de la recta de amarillo su pendiente va
a ser el inverso negativo
de este 4 por lo tanto el inverso
multiplicativo es 1 entre m y negativo
por lo tanto la ecuación de esta recta
de amarillo va a ser
igual a menos 1 entre m todo esto por x
más otra intersección con el eje de las
yes y bueno otra forma de verlo sería
decir que si dos rectas son
perpendiculares entonces el producto de
sus pendientes es igual a menos 1 así
que vamos a escribirlo esto es muy
importante m x menos 1 / m
esto va a ser estos 24 se van a cancelar
y entonces me va a quedar menos 1 así
que regresando el problema vamos a
encontrar las pendientes de estas rectas
y vamos a ver si alguna de ellas cumple
que su pendiente es el inverso negativa
de alguna de las demás en la recta am
aquí está muy fácil porque ya está en la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen por
lo tanto sabemos que su pendiente es
igual a 3 es decir a esta recta ya no
hay que modificarle nada porque sabemos
que su pendiente m es igual a 3
ahora vamos a fijarnos
lo que pasa con la recta y con la recta
en la recta b no está en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen así que
vamos a despejar ayer para obtener así
la pendiente de esta recta y para
despejar ayer primero tenemos x + 3 bien
esto es igual a menos 21 de aquí vamos a
partir y lo que voy a hacer es restar x
de ambos lados de la ecuación así que
menos x de este lado y de este otro lado
también menos x y ahora x y menos x
estos dos se van es justo lo que yo
quiero y me va a quedar que 3 siempre es
igual a menos x menos 21 a menos x menos
21 y ahora para despejar ayer lo que voy
a hacer es dividir todo entre 3 tanto el
lado izquierdo como el lado derecho de
tal manera que estos dos se van a
cancelar y del lado izquierdo solamente
me queda yen mientras que el lado
derecho me queda menos un tercio de x
menos 21 entre 3 lo cual es 7 y ya con
esto podemos ver que la pendiente de
esta recta es igual a menos un tercio y
vamos a apuntar lo
diente de la recta b es igual a menos un
tercio y ahora guau
fíjate que estas dos pendientes son
inversas negativas la una de la otra si
tú tomas el inverso multiplicativo de
tres es un tercio y este es el negativo
de ese mismo o si tú tomas el inverso
multiplicativo de menos un tercio es
menos tres y aquí tenemos el negativo de
ese mismo y waha o esto está de lujo
porque ahora podemos decir que estas dos
rectas en definitiva son dos rectas
perpendiculares perpendiculares ahora
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con la
recta cm si te das cuenta la recta se
tampoco está en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen por lo tanto vamos a
despejar a james de esta ecuación y
tengo 3x más james es igual a 10 y para
despejar a james lo que voy a hacer es
restar 3x de ambos lados de la ecuación
de tal manera que del lado izquierdo
estos dos se van a cancelar y me queda
simple y sencillamente que james es
igual a menos 3 x +
y ya con esto encontramos la pendiente
la pendiente de la recta cm es igual a
menos 3 y date cuenta que está pendiente
es la negativa de esta otra pendiente
sin embargo no es el inverso
multiplicativo por otra parte está
pendiente es el inverso multiplicativo
de esta otra de la recta bem sin embargo
no es negativa no cumplen con que una es
negativa y la otra es positiva por lo
tanto mi respuesta es que la recta am y
la recta b son perpendiculares